In order to create
an application where you
can chat with your data,
you first have to load
your data into a format
where it can be worked with. That's
where LangChain document loaders
come into play. We
have over 80 different
types of document loaders, and
in this lesson we'll cover
a few of the
most important ones and
get you comfortable with
the concept in general.
Let's jump in!
Document loaders deal
with the specifics of accessing and
converting data from a variety of
different formats and
sources into a standardized format.
There can be different
places that we want
to load data from, like websites,
different databases, YouTube,
and these documents can
come in different data types,
like PDFs, HTML, JSON.
And so the whole
purpose of document loaders
is to take this
variety of data sources
and load them into
a standard document object.
Which consists of content
and then associated metadata.
There are a lot
of different type of
document loaders in LangChain,
and we won't
have time to cover them all, but
here is a rough
categorization of the 80
plus that we have. There
are a lot that deal
with loading unstructured data, like
text files, from
public data sources, like
YouTube, Twitter, Hacker News, and
there are also even more that
deal with loading
unstructured data from
the proprietary data
sources that you or your company
might have, like Figma, Notion.
Document loaders can also be
used to load structured data.
Data that's in a tabular format
and may just have
some text data in one of those cells
or rows that you
still want to do
question answering or semantic
search over. And
so the sources here
include things like Airbyte, Stripe,
Airtable.
Alright, now let's
jump into the fun stuff, actually
using document loaders. First,
we're going to load some environment variables
that we need, like the
OpenAI API key.
The first type of documents that we're
going to be working with are PDFs. So
let's import the relevant document loader
from Langchain. We're going to
use the PyPDF loader.
We've loaded a bunch of
PDFs into the documents
folder in the workspace, and
so let's choose
one and put that in the loader.
Now let's load the documents by just
calling the load method.
Let's
take a look at what exactly we've loaded.
So this, by default, will load
a list of documents.
In this case, there are 22 different
pages in this PDF.
Each one is its own unique document.
Let's take a look at the first one
and see what it consists of.
The first thing
the document consists of is some
page content,
which is the content of the page.
This can be a bit long, so let's
just print out the
first few hundred characters.
The other piece of information that's
really important is the metadata associated
with each document. This
can be accessed with
the metadata element.
You can see here that there's
two different pieces. One
is the source information. This
is the PDF, the
name of the file that
we loaded it from. The
other is the page field. This
corresponds to the page
of the PDF that it was loaded from.
The next type of
document loader that we're
going to look at is
one that loads from YouTube.
There's
a lot of fun content on YouTube, and
so a lot of people use this document
loader to be able
to ask questions of
their favorite videos or
lectures or anything like that.
We're going to import a
few different things here. The
key parts are the
YouTube audio loader, which
loads an audio file
from a YouTube video. The
other key part is
the OpenAI Whisper parser. This
will use OpenAI's Whisper
model, a speech-to-text model, to convert
the YouTube audio into a text
format that we can
work with.
We can now specify a URL,
specify a directory in which
to save the audio files,
and then create the generic loader
as a combination of this YouTube
audio loader combined
with the OpenAI Whisper parser.
And then we can call "loader.load" to
load the documents corresponding
to this YouTube.
This may take a few minutes, so we're
going to speed this up and post. Now
that it's finished loading, we can
take a look at the page
content of what we've loaded. And
this is the first part of
the transcript from the
YouTube video. This is a
good time to pause, go choose your
favorite YouTube video, and see if
this transcription works for
you.
The next set of documents that we're
going to go over how to
load are URLs from the Internet.
There's a lot of really awesome educational
content on the Internet, and
wouldn't it be cool if you could
just chat with it?
We're going to enable that
by importing the web-based loader
from LangChain. Then we
can choose any URL, our favorite
URL. Here, we're going to
choose a markdown file
from this GitHub page
and create a loader
for it. And then next,
we can call loader.load, and then we
can take a look at the content
of the page. Here, you'll notice there's
a lot of white space,
followed by some initial text, and
then some more text. This
is a good example of
why you actually need to do some post-processing
on the information to get it
into a workable
format.
Finally, we'll
cover how to load data from Notion. Notion
is a really popular
store of both personal
and company data, and
a lot of people
have created chatbots talking
to their Notion databases. In
your notebook, you'll see
instructions on how to export data
from your Notion
database into a format through which
we can load it into LangChain.
Once we have it in that format,
we can use the
Notion directory loader to
load that data and
get documents that we can work with.
If we take a look at the content here,
we can see that it's
in markdown format, and
this Notion document is from Blendle's
Employee Handbook. I'm sure a
lot of people listening
have used Notion and
have some Notion databases
that they would like
to chat with, and so this
is a great opportunity to go
export that data, bring it in
here, and start working
with it in this
format.
That's it for document loading. Here,
we've covered how to load
data from a variety of sources
and get it into a standardized
document interface. However, these
documents
are still rather large, and so
in the next section, we're going to
go over how to split them up into
smaller chunks. This is relevant
and important because when
you're doing this retrieval
augmented generation, you
need to retrieve
only the pieces of
content that are most
relevant, and so you don't
want to select the whole documents that we've
loaded here, but rather only
the paragraph or few sentences that
are most topical to what you're
talking about.
This is also an
even better opportunity to
think about what sources
of data we don't
currently have loaders for, but
you might still want to explore. Who
knows? Maybe you can even make
a PR to LangChain.